far-right violence here in germany is on
the rise that's according to the
country's interior ministry
authorities recorded more than eight and
a half thousand offenses
in the first half of this year and many
people have reason to fear they could be
targeted
their names have appeared on far-right
enemy lists distributed online
the interior ministry has said the lists
do not pose a tangible threat but
critics say authorities are not taking
matters
seriously enough
ruben neugebauer's name is on an enemy
list put together by right-wing
extremists
they also put his address online in an
attempt to scare him
and his colleagues
we get
sometimes these death threats are very
concrete
it's something we live with and we've
made a decision to deal with it
so we're not intimidated
the reason ruben neugebauer is on this
list is that he works for sea watch
an organization that rescues refugees in
distress
at sea
right-wing extremists are constantly
uploading lists of their political
opponents
online the same list that ruben
neugebauer is on also includes
journalists
ngo team members and politicians
sometimes with
insults next to their names another list
highlights jews
their names are marked with a star of
david and although the authorities are
aware of these lists
in most german states they have not
informed the people who are named
are authorities taking this matter
seriously enough
in june conservative politician valta
libka was shot dead by an alleged
right-wing extremist
libka's name had appeared on a list
compiled by the nsu
an extreme right terror network
the victims advice center reach out
documents right wing and racist attacks
unlike the german interior ministry
workers here think the lists are
definitely dangerous
maybe not right now but that could be
the case
in the future so the danger of these
lists
is really being played down
funker is an expert on right-wing
extremism
he wants the authorities to be more
transparent and better at communicating
especially where it concerns those who
have already experienced hostility
and are now more of a target than ever
these people are already in danger now
even more
has no idea who put him on the list but
it won't stop him doing what he believes
in
and saving the lives of refugees out at
sea
our political correspondent emmanuel is
covering this this story for us and
joins us now amano do we have any idea
how many people are actually on these
lists that the
far-right groups are keeping well
actually thousands of people are
affected the last list that was made
public
is a list of 25 000 people that was
compiled by a far right
a group called not coins that has been
uh uncovered
uh earlier uh this year we also had
earlier on this year a hashtag trending
on twitter virgrigen
which means we will get you all uh these
hashtag compiled the names of about 200
people
who were targeted by far-right
sympathizers there was also a much
smaller list
compiled by a german soldier he had
compiled 23
names that he deem of individuals he
deemed uh
being enemies of the state and of course
earlier on
uh the nsu the national socialist
underground whose members
had committed 10 racially motivated
murders in germany between 2000
and 2007 had also compiled such a list
of about
10 000 people how do these right-wing
groups who
who publish these names on the internet
and obviously using social media
how do they go about compiling them well
by hacking websites that's the main
uh that's the main way of gathering data
when i talk about data it's not only
names of people
politicians public figures journalists
it's also their personal addresses
their phone numbers so all uh the
information that
might be that might help identify them
and their whereabouts
what's the interior ministry in germany
doing about that justice authorities are
they
going after these uh these these
right-wing groups who publish these
lists
well uh upon uncovering uh such a list
the government would uh actually process
to uh proceed to a risk assessment so
are
the threats real is this just a list or
is it a death list
is there a concrete uh threat uh being
made we know that walter lupko the
politician killed in june this year
was on such a list so there's a risk
assessment and then
the government goes on to inform uh the
people
who who are on those lists and to and
they try to assess whether they are at
risk
some people are placed under protection
but many
uh many suspects are under civilians but
only
like for example more than 2
500 people are suspects in far-right
crimes
nationwide but only 23 of them
were actually arrested okay i guess the
priority
should also be to protect those who are
truly uh threatened by those right-wing
groups and manuel shah's my political
desk thank you so much
thank you